thank you such a pleasure to be here I'm
looking forward to this discussion
please treat this as interactive feel
free to ask questions stop me for
clarification of her questions or
discussion at any point I probably got
too much material to get through in an
hour so just keep on it there won't be
any time at the ends it just stopped me
whenever you feel like it and also if
you find I'm talking too quickly or
anything like that I can have a habit of
doing stop me for that reason to a
little bit more about my background
actually studied physics initially and
then economics first job I ever had was
designing the cause of nuclear reactors
a work for United Kingdom Atomic Energy
Authority science are quite familiar
with all of your business after that I
became an economist and I actually work
for a while for OPEC and was the
economic adviser to the Secretary
General of OPEC so I saw it sort of the
producer side of oil markets for a
number of years and familiar with that
area too but I'm not really going to
talk about either of those things to
them my focus is on carbon and energy
markets in the US now the young US
doesn't really have much in the way of
carbon markets so we can deal with
carbon markets in maybe 10 minutes most
of today will be we're talking about
energy markets so as you've heard I'm
sure from mike girard yesterday the US
doesn't have at least the federal level
carbon markets there is no federal
legislation which is currently limiting
carbon emissions at least not through a
market mechanism and the EPA the
Environmental Protection Agency is about
to produce some regulations on the
emission of carbon by large point
sources but we don't know exactly what
those regulations will be at this point
and they certainly won't be market-based
there will be sort of command and
control regulations of some sort there
is however one regional carbon market as
Mike told you yesterday this is the
Northeast states have a Regional
Greenhouse Gas Initiative affectionately
known as Reggie and that tell us about
988 of the Northeast states in the u.s.
it's not a particularly powerful
restriction on carbon emissions it's the
position system it is based very much on
the European Union's emission trading
scheme so that's the same it's the same
intellectual framework as that which in
turn was actually very similar to the US
sulfur dioxide trading scheme it was
introduced in 1990 it applies only to
electric utilities so I need two very
very large point sources just a bit
slower oh sure so it applies the this
applies only to electric utilities and
the price on carbon current is very low
so it's about five dollars a ton the
reason primarily for that is that the
carbon permits were allocated before the
recession and Adam and electricity has
dropped sharply during the recession and
therefore the demand for permits is
dropped till you've seen the same thing
in Europe obviously that's a very
similar story there the permits will be
reallocated in a year and a half and so
maybe in two or three years from now
we'll see a higher price for carbon on
this market but right now it's not a
major factor in the in the decision
making for utilities however there's a
general expectation within the US that
within 10 years there will be some kind
of restrictions serious restrictions on
the emission of carbon we don't know
whether there'll be market-based or some
other form so you'll find that most
utilities in the US when they make
investment plans are assuming that there
will be some form of price on carbon
during the lifetime of the power station
till they go to build there's a lot of
confusion unfortunate exactly what that
will be and that's a major shortcoming
of US policy right now in uncertainty is
never good obviously for corporations
making long-term decisions there's a lot
of uncertainty in the US California as
I'm sure mike girard also told you has
announced that it will introduce a
cap-and-trade system a carbon market
starting next year the details are
available the general expectation is it
will be a somewhat tighter cap than the
Northeast states I have futures on that
are trading at about seven or eight
dollars for a ton of carbon dioxide
right now
they could potentially their bait let's
based on guesses on those guesses could
turn out to be wrong but the expectation
it will be slightly tighter and it's
possible that the other West Coast
states Oregon and Washington State or
join California so you will have
effectively to Regional Greenhouse Gas
markets one in the northeast of the US
and one on the west coast of the US now
in addition to the these carbon markets
something which is much more common in
the u.s. is what is called a renewable
portfolio standard 30 of the 50 states
now have these and these are effectively
markets for the absence of carbon to
sort of a negative carbon market so many
ways it sets up the same incentive
structure as a carbon market in a
carbonyl market you're charged for
producing carbon in a renewable
portfolio standard you're paid for not
producing carbon so it's much the same
concept in sidon attempt to level the
playing field and to make carbon-based
energy more expensive relative to non
carbon-based energy the politics of this
is that the fossil fuel industry in the
u.s. is very big and very powerful it's
been able to block any moves to tax the
use of fossil fuels so instead the
government has had to move to
subsidizing non-fossil fuels when you
see some of that in Europe obviously in
germany in spain and italy for the
feed-in tariffs but that's basically the
main policy lever here in the US
subsidizing non-fossil fuels and this
happens at the state level so these are
30 states and each of these states
unfortunately has its own separate
policy so the regulations about subsidy
stand non-fossil fuels in New York are
quite different from those across the
river over there in New Jersey quite
significantly different which is the
only means you get people are shifting
their power stations from one side of a
state border to another just to take
advantage of big differences in the
regulatory framework quite a number of
US corporations have shifted data
processing headquarters for example from
New York to New
Jersey because there are very big
subsidies for using solar power in New
Jersey New Jersey ironically has become
the Germany of the u.s. it's the state
with the most solar power installed even
though rather like Germany it's not a
particularly sunny estate it's it's
complicated yeah I mean the most let me
get into the details of these things
before try to come back to their
questions let me take let me explain a
little bit more about how these things
work so renewable portfolio standard
basically requires that a certain
percentage so X percent of all electric
power is generated from renewable
resources and that X varies from state
to state and also what is defined as
renewable varies from state to state so
hydro may be renewable in some states
and not in others nuclear may be
renewable in some states and not in
others okay these these these
requirements that a certain percentage
be generated renewably is accompanied by
what's called a renewable energy
certificate market and as a wreck market
so here's the story behind these if you
produce one megawatt hour of power using
say wind or solar or some other
acceptable renewable base that generates
a certificate called the rec renewable
energy certificate which just a piece of
paper saying in a 1 megawatt hour power
was produced using renewable resources
if you're a utility then to conform with
this regulation at the end of the year
you have to present to the regulator a
pile of these renewable energy
certificates equal to X percent of the
number of megawatt hours that you
generated during the year and the
producers of renewable power can sell
these so if i'm running a wing farm i
produce the power and i sell the power
then i also produce renewable energy
certificates and i sell during your
granny's tickets and i'm a get and i'll
show you some numbers on this as much
money for the certificates as i do for
the pound in fact in some cases i get
more money for certificates than i do
for the power
so this is a major factor obligation
suppliers on the distributor's the
retail distributors so here will be con
it for example who has to do they know
the markets a state-specific which comes
back to your earlier question yeah it
markets a state-specific there are some
bilateral agreements between states
where there are as where there is a big
interconnection between the grits but in
general the markets are state specific
and I'll show you some data on the
prices and you'll see they're very
different in different markets so these
renewable energy certificates basically
are a financial reward for producing non
non-fossil energy producing non-carbon
energy from non carbon sources and I
think this light synthesis what I've
said already so this is just an example
of some of the difference some of the
different renewable portfolio standards
on a state-by-state basis I took this
from is a very useful adoption of the
United States energy information agency
EIA annual energy outlook so the energy
information agency produces the annual
energy outlook every year and it's a
very sort of comprehensive summary
what's happening in the policy area
energy policy area in the United States
it's available on the website so this is
just the first of a 44 pages of
summaries of what these laws are like
state-by-state so I guess review the
first one Arizona Arizona corporate
commission decision number 69 127
requires fifteen percent of electricity
sales to be renewable by 2025 with
interim goals increasing annually so
Arizona have fifteen percent of power
renewable by 2025 California
thirty-three percent by 2020 so many
point if I difference in each of those
states listed there has a different goal
and a different timetable for release
realizing that goal
so utilities in different states very
very different regulatory regimes but
what is common is in all of these
context you guys simply get paid as a
power producer you get paid for not
producing carbon so these are just so
yes yes yes even Texas occupation here
make sure this is the well there is the
Texas price so these are the prices of
wrecks renewable energy certificates in
various different states over the period
so thousand two two two thousand seven I
mean the point about this graph is quite
simply these are dollars per
megawatt-hour to some recs or as little
as six dollars a megawatt hour somewhere
as much as fifty dollars a megawatt hour
and they vary a lot in overtime and they
vary a lot across states so this is a
very heterogeneous policy environment
and if you're a multi-state utility many
utilities are multi-state and you have
to reckon with all of these different
prices and of course obviously with the
fluctuations that you may see in these
prices so it's a it's a it's a tricky
area um Connecticut there was discussion
about removing the restriction and
changing the policy which the price
dropped and then it they decided not to
the Christ came back up again and this
is actually New Jersey this is New
Jersey has a specific market for solar
power so new so these these are markets
for any kind of renewable in New Jersey
you actually have a market specifically
for solar renewable energy certificates
which is why New Jersey has this huge
concentration of solar power I was
referring to just now and the New Jersey
market reached another this period of
time rich set up to 210 bellows megawatt
hour remember the retail price of
electricity in the u.s. until the
wholesale price is about fifty dollars a
megawatt out so this is four times the
wholesale price of the power so for
every megawatt hour you're producing
you're getting fifty dollars on the
market and another 200
dollars in the rec market no the utility
utility has to conform to the
requirement here yeah salut right so
they really r utility has to produce x
percent twenty percent thirty percent
are in rugeley its solar specifically
solo yeah yeah that's the reason for the
well the power company is paying to buy
these certificates so the power company
has to be the utility the utility the
distributor the distributor has to buy
these certificates the cost of the
certificates is then incorporated in the
Christ account so ultimately the
consumer pays yes absolutely a wrister
sermon here in New York the retail price
of power is about fifteen cents a
kilowatt hour in Texas it's about eight
cents a kilowatt hour in Hawaii it's 22
cents a kilowatt hour and this price of
power at the retail level varies greatly
from state to state there's no arbitrage
No basically there is no arbitrage no
yeah the u.s. the grid in the u.s. is
not the national grid does not have the
ability to shift power across large
distances at peak times
it's probably the u.s. is a less
connected group than Europe Patrick oh
right yes if you think what do you think
of states as countries it's very similar
yes yeah absolutely yeah yeah that's
right and there's not even there's
nothing like that in the u.s. there's no
general agreement of the u.s. yeah and
that's right i think that the the euro
europe is more interconnected it is more
of a backbone period and there is in the
US yeah yeah the so that when these
these the cost of these difficulties is
incorporated in the final price to the
consumer so yeah so so so what's the
question exactly oh I see what part of
the invoice Oh of the retail price
probably in some cases as much as twenty
five percent of retail price yes is this
not in all cases because the prices are
so different but but in the in case of
New Jersey with the solar price yes yes
okay um so in addition to the these
renewable energy certificates there are
other incentives to produce non-fossil
to use non-fossil fuels in the US
there's a thing called the production
tax credit available for the generation
of renewable energy so for every
megawatt hour of renewable energy that
you produce you can get a tax credit
there are also investment tax credits in
for every every every kilowatt of
generating capacity that you build of
renewable energy you can get a tax
credit and so there are in a significant
incentives this is just a this is a
solar power station in Colorado and this
is a an analysis of the different
sources of the net present value of
revenues from the program over its
lifetime
so energy sales make up eight percent of
the lifetime revenue accelerated
depreciation 22% investment tax credit
25% sale of renewable energy
certificates forty-two percent so
basically this guy is not producing
energy he's producing certificates which
is a strange situation and then means of
the economics of an operation like this
and this is a very typical for a solar
power station in the u.s. today the
economics of an operation like this is
very dependent on policy you know this
this this restraint here has changed the
economics can change dramatically you
would like to think that you know
cheaper solar panels would increase the
profitability but cheaper solar panels
might increase this from eight percent
to twelve percent another the make or
break here was still with the regulatory
frameworks
yeah I didn't do the calculation I think
you're probably yes we might be I see
where you're coming from yeah I took
their that's this actually comes from
another point useful website in this
area will just nrel National Renewable
Energy Lab which is actually based in
colorado a lot yeah ok so that's it for
carbon markets for the US so the rest of
my talk I'll talk about fossil fuels
coal gas and oil and what's interesting
I peps a lot about Outsiders don't
really quite understand it's just how
big the u.s. is in all of these markets
so this is just some data on sources of
energy primary energy in the US the
biggest primary energy source in the US
is oil followed by gas and coal the u.s.
is completely self-sufficient in coal
it's self sufficient in gas and it
produces a lot of oil but it's not
self-sufficient you can see for example
from this that 93% of the coal goes to
produce electricity but ninety-four
percent of the oil goes into
transportation so basically oil equals
transportation co leapers electricity
and natural gas goes in all possible
directions but no petroleum is used in
producing but virtually no petroleum is
used in producing electricity in the US
coal and gas are much cheaper wind is
cheaper solar is even cheaper than extra
than oil let's talk about cole OOP
receipts the most widespread source of
power both in the US and worldwide it
produces a huge amount of co2 and other
pollutants so its various India it's
economics is very sensitive to
environmental policies we just saw their
down so this is a US coal production
there are three basic coal producing
regions there's the interior which means
Illinois the area around Chicago
appellate show which means the sort of
the weight of the east coast south east
of the US which is West Virginia
primarily and then the West which means
Wyoming and Montana that's the powder
river basin and the paranoia of a base
in the West Coast the West Western
Western Regional are in the Rockies is
the area where coal production in the
u.s. is growing
rapidly production and this of the older
coal field in Appalachia is dropping off
prices vary the west coast coal is the
least the West Western coal Wyoming
Powder River Basin is the cheapest cheap
because of transportation costs you've
got to put it on a train and move it
1,500 miles to get it to any decent
markets but it's also cheap with its low
quality low thermal content types offer
content but and this is dollars per
million BTUs so I'm showing the prices
here in dollars Pemberley and BTUs you
can compare this for example with with
natural gas which is also priced in
dollars per million btu and this sorrel
you're looking here at a dollar a
million btu for Western coal let's do it
cheap you know I mean you're paying in
Europe you're paying for gas you're
paying ten dollars a million btu here in
the US natural gas is three and a half
dollars a million btu so this is really
really cheap so colas is it the most
exciting see payment yet oh coal prices
have tended to follow other fossil fuel
prices I mean it's possible to
substitute between coal and oil and some
place some applications so that's really
just a run-up because of that this is an
internal market yes this is us doesn't
import and barely exports exporting a
little bit some discussion now of
putting in a railway railroad from the
Powder River Basin through the rocky
mountains to the west coast to ship
coldest to China but at this point the
u.s. is basically a self-contained
market worldwide reserves of coal us has
a quarter of the world's reserves of
coal far bigger than anywhere else so we
think you're lost trailers a big coal
producer its reserves of peanuts beside
the u.s. u.s. is a huge huge coelicolor
country which is why you know we have a
lot of the fossil fuel industry there's
a lot of leverage here production
biggest producer of coal
is China with the u.s. coming number two
but China's are reserved to production
ratio is really quite low China has
about 30 odd years of coal left at
current rates of consumption and China
is currently moving to import as i'm
sure you all know large quantities of
college importing a lot from australia
and will be important from the US before
long the US and Russia have massive
reserve to production ratios obviously
so it's a lot of coal left in the world
that's not a very good thing
unfortunately from an environmental
perspective but there's a lot of cold
out there technology most us power
stations are very old-fashioned they've
just pulverized coal power stations they
just crush the coal inject a jet of
finely ground coal into a burner and
burn it produces a lot of pollution and
has a very very low thermal efficiency
usually under forty percent there's two
power stations in the US the Jews IGCC
could technologies so they gasify the
coal and then put the gas through a
combined cycle power station that gets
you you know efficiencies up to about
sixty percent sixty-five percent but the
capital costs are quite a lot higher but
the capital cost of a pulverized coal
power station in the u.s. is eighteen
hundred dollars for a kilowatt of
capacity so they're fairly cheap they
got them all like three thousand dollars
if you if you go 24 hour idcc power
station um so the obviously the big
issue with Colin's very source of a lot
of debate here in the US is the
environmental impact you know each ton
of coal produces about two and a half
tons of carbon dioxide when you burn it
so burning coal is the biggest source of
carbon dioxide in the u.s. biggest
source of carbon dioxide worldwide but
it's also a source of other important
particulate importunity when you burn
coal particularly these pulverized coal
power stations a lot of fine particles
go into the air and they get into the
lungs and cause respiratory diseases and
of course there's lots of accidents in
the coal mining area that's just a
picture of a coal mine it's another
aspect of the environmental impact of
towing coal production this is a coal
mine in West Virginia
what they called mountaintop removal
just cut the top off the hill and dig
down into it produces a huge amount of
debris it destroys the landscape this is
it also very controversial there's a
number of groups in the u.s. trying to
stop mountaintop removal but currently
most of the color production in the u.s.
it's your techniques like this it's not
there's very little deep money deep
mining is expensive so there's some deep
mining for very rich scenes but most of
this is surface mining like this you
shouldn't blame for three this is just
some headlines I took from a website
called medscape air pollution blame for
three percent of deaths the United
States and most of that would be a coal
related Switzerland France and Austria
World Congress on lung diseases were
p.m. tens in these three countries
responsible for 40,000 death co and most
of those p.m. tens would be coming from
either diesel or coal and probably
mostly from coal so we coal is very
dangerous just some data on from a world
bank report it was in draft form that
was when I took this diagram from it on
deaths from coal pull up for air
pollution in China most of which again I
related to cult the production of coal
so I mean call you probably estimate the
coal pollution is responsible for
several million deaths worldwide every
year and sir coal pollution is a big
issue quite apart from the greenhouse
gas and the climate change dimension is
that right yeah skipped fees so the one
of the things which is under a lot of
discussion in the US is whether it's
possible to produce what's called clean
coal and clean coal because it goes to a
igcc power station so you gasify the
coal and you put it through a combined
cycle power station but you'd also have
a carbon capture and storage system on
the smokestack which would take the co2
out of the out of the smokestack and
store that liquefy the co2 and storage
someone currently there are no
commercial scale implementations of this
anywhere in the world there is carbon
capture and storage it's like 'no you
know this is the state'll field in off
the coast of norway statoil is bringing
up oil with a mixture of natural gas and
carbon dioxide they're stripping the
carbon dioxide out capturing it
liquefying it and pumping it back into
the fields
they've been doing that for about 15
years now that's the same similar
technique been used in Algeria in a
joint venture between BP and sauna track
they're taking the co2 out of natural
gas which is heavy and co2 liquefying it
and pumping it back down so the
technologies for capturing natural gas
capturing co2 out of an exhaust stream
exist but the lot of debate about
exactly how much it would cost to make
Co to make make coal power stations
carbon neutral and the general thinking
is that currently coal energy of
electricity from coal costs around about
six or seven cents per kilowatt hour as
I saw the levelized cost and the capital
costs of roughly two thousand dollars if
you were to make if you will require
coal-fired power stations to capture
their co2 and store it but probably add
two to four cents to this so you've been
looking at something like ten or eleven
cents eight nine ten or eleven cents as
opposed to six to seven cents a kilowatt
hour that doesn't sound like a huge
number and even ten cents eleven cents
is less than the retail price but that's
a lot more than natural gas and it's a
lot more than wind so that would be
enough to make cold through and it will
nuclear in the US it's complicated it
depends on what you assume about capital
costs on a new nuclear power station
yeah yeah and an existing power station
you're quite right yeah yeah absolutely
yeah okay so let's talk quickly about
natural gas this is actually where all
the excitement in US energy market says
have been some hugely obviously all well
aware they've been huge discoveries of
natural gas in the u.s. in the US has
moved to being more or less self
sufficient in natural gas and indeed
there's no discussion of the u.s.
becoming a gas exporter so the US could
end up exporting both gasp and and coal
this is currently probably will
certainly the cheapest fossil fuel so
you can vidiyum in the capital costs of
conventional gas power stations are very
low so you can build the gas power
station for five hundred to a thousand
dollars at kilowatt at capacity which
means it's very attractive for example
as a peaking plant in all of the peaking
plants that cover in a peak demand in
the US are obviously natural gas placed
but we're seeing more and more base load
power come from natural gas plants too
and one of the interesting things that's
beginning to happen is a transition from
coal to gas as a base load power source
and that's because no natural gas is now
less expensive than coal on earth of La
levelized cost basis and given the the
pollution issues associated with Colt
and the fact that action will probably
be taken on those a natural gas look
attractive relative to call the natural
gas obviously produces co2 as well but
it produces less co2 per megawatt hour
then told us so natural gas will be less
affected by pricing carbon dioxide or by
a requirement to capture carbon dioxide
than coal wood so that natural gas looks
like a good bet to many utilities and no
coal power stations have been built in
the US for four or five years now all
the new power stations built in the US
in the last four or five years have been
either natural gas or wind natural gas
and wind between them account for about
eighty percent eighty-five percent of
capacity additions in the last five
years in the US so basically the US is
going ahead on a mixture of gas and wind
and actually they fit quite well
together because of the intermittency of
wind and the fact that you can turn gas
power stations up and down very quickly
I mean gas is a good fuel for backing up
a wind field there's no obviously
there's no world market for gas as you
guys know there's a we've got a North
American market were the prices around
about four dollars a million btu you
better European market which is roughly
twice that eight dollars
dollars a million btu and there's an
asian market which 12 for $13 million
btu so the prices are 123 in the US
Europe and Asia roughly speaking and
there's no arbitrage because it's so
expensive to move gasps around you know
you've got a piper build a huge pipeline
and the pipeline's coming out of Russia
to Western Europe cost you 20 billion
dollars to build or you've got to build
an LNG train to liquefy natural gas
you've got to build the lake look at
that LNG tankers and then you've got a
building a regasification plant at the
receiving end and leaves LNG compressors
costs five to ten billion dollars and
the regasification plants cost two or
three billion dollars to the capital
costs of moving gasps around a very high
so this point we really have very
different prices in very different
regions that may change you know we may
see so you know given given the size of
the differential prices in the
differential comprises we may see more
development of LNG technology you know
it would be attractive obviously to take
gas from the US at 33 dollars a million
btu and sell it in Asia ten dollars a
million btu so what people looking into
that but right now you've got three
separate regional markets and the u.s.
is the cheapest okay okay this is just
some data on gas prices in sort of Japan
European Union the u.s. henry hub which
is the sort of the basic of the price
place for prices are generally measured
at and osed as a whole as i said the
prices range vary widely across these
different regions okay gasps relative to
coal sorry relative to oil this is the
ratio of the price of oil to the price
of gas on a thermal equivalent spaces
okay so this means that currently gas is
one third of the price of oil in terms
of a per unit of energy generated so oil
is just not used for generating
electricity in the u.s. at all given the
abundance of gas and abundance of coal
us gas production
forecast by the Energy Information
Administration we're now right here the
variety of sources coalbed methane
offshore onshore and then these are the
two new sources of gas in particular
this one here shale gas gas coming out
of shale production gasp which is
produced through hydraulic fracturing of
shale deposits that's what is growing
really really quickly us reserves of gas
is some debate about these the energy
information agency puts him at about 300
trillion cubic feet which is about 1213
years of production the industry puts
them at two thousand trillion cubic feet
an independent estimate by the
engineering department at MIT put it at
six hundred and fifty trillion cubic
feet so there's some so some lack of
clarity about the size particular these
shale gas reserves those are these are
the ones that have been discovered
recently and are being produced on an
increasing scale we're not totally
certain how much is inside these and
that's where the main argument is
between the EIA the industry and the
engineers at MIT however it's clear that
the US has at least a hundred years of
gas available at current consumption
rates and maybe 200 years of gas
available at current consumption rates
so the US has hundreds of years of coal
and hundreds of years of gas basically
and the u.s. education where the largest
gas reserves in the world you know
because of this on this dispute about
the size of the shale reserves difficult
enough exactly where it rates but it
could be number one it could be number
two or number three but it's right up
there amongst the top countries in terms
of size of its gas reserves now there's
been some debate recently about whether
natural gas is in fact as climate
friendly as it been conventionally
thought if you read going to standard
literature from a few years back on the
carbon footprint of gas versus coal and
what you'll find there it says that the
carbon footprint of gas is about half
that of cold there's been some arguments
I won't go into I don't have time to go
into detail but some argument about
whether that's
particularly when gas coming from shale
the real point here is that when you
fracture when you're hydraulically
fracture shale then some of the natural
gas escapes not up the pipeline but into
the atmosphere and methane is a very
powerful greenhouse gas much more pang
as a much higher global warming
potential than co2 so if you escape even
small amounts of methane into directly
into the atmosphere it actually increase
the overall carbon footprint the overall
global warming potential of natural gas
significantly so there's a lot of debate
at the moment about exactly how much
methane leaks from fractured shale rock
directly into the atmosphere relative to
coming up the pipeline where it's
supposed to come and how much this can
be reduced and the assumption seems to
be that it can be reduced in I think the
general status that is this argument
right now is that some of the first
operations to hydraulically fracture
shale rock and extract gas were very
poorly conducted conducted to very low
standards in engineering terms we've got
a lot of pollution of ground water from
the water that's pumped down for the
hydraulic fracturing as a lot of
environmental damage there a lot of
natural gas leaking out and so these
statements here might well have been
correct for there but the assumptions
that with better regulation and also
been somewhat bigger companies most of
the one of my friends in the engineering
field said that put it this way that the
the first people in the gas fracking
business we're Cowboys these were small
independent operators with very low
operation on that most safety standards
little capitalization little concern
about the long run in packs of what
they're doing they go in there a.m. to
find the gas start producing gas then
sell out to somebody else and their
their interest in zuv the long term
performance of their worlds is very
limited when these wells are taken over
by bigger companies which is
increasingly happening they'll be
operated to higher standards that that's
the hope anyone then it hasn't happened
yet but that's the hope okay let me skip
that
so the bottom line is that gas in the
u.s. is cheap it's abundant it's a very
flexible power source you can turn gas
plants on and off very quickly which
makes it as i said before very good for
backing out window for backing up solar
power well you know the power to drop
away very quickly impact on climate is
unclear an impact on groundwater it's
the environmental impact particularly of
shale gas is something which is still a
source of concern finally oil oil as I
said before is basically just used for
transportation there's no oil power
stations some heavy oil or busy is burnt
directly for heating and but basically
oil goes into heating now the heavy oils
going to heating and then all of the
night oils go into transportation and
you can see that here 1% of oil remember
you saw this before ghost of power at
seventy two percent goes into
transportation ninety-four percent of
Transportation is powered by oil
worldwide consumption of oil is 84
million barrels a day a barrel is a is
42 u.s. gallons in liters that must be
about a hundred liters right yeah that's
so that's in terms of ballots at annual
leads 32 billion barrels so now of this
84 million barrels consumed worldwide
daily the US consumers 20 million so the
US consumers about a quarter of all oil
produced worldwide so it's a massive st.
sync for oil the big producers will see
the big producers here citizen data on
oil production to be looked at 2009
Saudi Arabia was producing roughly
10,000 barrels a day 10 so 10 million
barrels a day Russia slightly more in
2009 the United States very slightly
less and everybody else is much much
smaller so the u.s. is either the second
or the third biggest oil producer in the
world depending on what's happening in
Russia Saudi Arabia is always number one
and then Russia and number in the US and
number 2's by
crude oil producers but the u.s. still
has to import a lot because its
consumption although its production is
huge its consumption is even more huge
so the US imports about forty-eight
percent of all of the oil used here in
spite of being such a big oil producer
this is where the oil imports come from
ironically the biggest single source of
oil imports is Venezuela so the US gets
most of its imports from Venezuela from
Canada and from Mexico us is actually
not dependent on Middle Eastern oil the
US gets its oil mainly from the from the
Western Hemisphere Venezuela Mexico
Canada there are some imports from the
Middle East some inputs from West Africa
some imports from the North Sea but
they're small and then mainly because of
that particular refineries any
particular types of crude but TV the
western hemisphere is largely
self-sufficient in oil so although the
u.s. there's a lot of politicking in the
u.s. about dependence on Middle Eastern
oil the u.s. is not dependent on Middle
Eastern oil except in the general sense
that if there's a major dislocation in
the Middle East obviously affects world
prices and so the US pays more price of
crude oil very volatile very volatile
indeed and it's interesting that back is
just relatively recently oil was trading
for twenty dollars a barrel that's back
in the 1990s gone up since then too well
it's gone up actually above this and
went very sharp spike briefly for about
one hundred and forty dollars the price
of wall has been rising a lot during the
course of this century who driven mainly
in other words a big price increases in
oil back here 273 is a 79 80 those price
increases were really driven by supply
interruptions so this was the
arab-israeli war an Arab oil embargo
this was the Iranian Revolution on the
war between the Iraq and Iran which took
both Iraq and Iran's oil off the market
those were supply interruptions
came back down after those interruptions
were taken away what's interesting about
this is there's no supply interruption
behind us this is entirely on the demand
side what's driving the price up here is
drawing demand in China drawing demand
in India growing demand in Asia in
general and if you look at war oil
consumption you'll find that oil
consumption the u.s. is actually flat
really quite flat for quite some time
now in fact there's a generous it's
generally thought that US oil
consumption may have peaked I know the
u.s. is moving to more fuel-efficient
vehicles slowly but is actually moving
that direction the higher price of all
these are having an impact in the u.s.
so us all production or consumption as
more or less peaked European oil
consumption is more or less peaked at
least in Western Europe so the what is
driving oil demand worldwide now is
entirely in Asia if you look at the
there are the data on this it's flat if
we're outside of Asia but growing
rapidly in Asia China is growing at
eight percent a year at that stage of
economic development countries have a
very high income elasticity of demand
for oil so you could see Chinese demand
for oil growing about fifteen percent to
you if your China is now a bigger oil
consumer than the bigger energy consumer
in total and a bigger oil consumer than
the u.s. so it's a big issue so this is
this is this is probably not a temporary
spike like these here because it's
coming from the demand side rather than
supply side if there's a big global
recession will see a drop again but will
pick up again after the recession this
is just what the energy information
agency again thinks is likely to happen
to other possible scenarios for oil
prices in the future the what is
interesting about this is that there is
they did this data here of course refers
to the convent the price of conventional
crude oil it is possible to get oil from
other sources so for example in Canada
there are the so-called tar sands which
is deposits of oil which occurring in
sensor rather than in conventional
sources so that you basically have to
mine this oil think you have a picture
of it somewhere here alright
yes so this is these are tar sands in
athabasca Canada and this is basically
Rock sent porous rock impregnated with
oil you take the rock out you crush it
and you heat it and you can liquefy the
oil and wash the oil out with water then
you put the oil and water mixture in big
ponds and you skim off the oil that's
expensive process quite expensive to get
oil out of tar sands about a hundred
dollars a barrel so you don't invest in
this mr. you think the price of oil is
going to be high for a long time but
quite a few big oil companies are now
investing in these tar sands what they
know this tar sands can produce a lot of
oil at somewhere in the region of a
hundred dollars barrel so if you really
believe these tar sands are going to be
big it sort of puts a cap on the price
of oil but we don't know enough about
the reserves there and the cost of
production at this point to be really
sure what the long-run impact of those
time zones will be it's also possible to
produce oil from coal and it's very
straightforward process trumbull during
the second world war the German army
around entirely on oil generated by from
colt there was no opposite germany has
no oil reserve lots of coal during the
apartheid era there was an oil embargo
on South Africa so all oil in South
Africa came from coal South Africa's big
coal reserves so you can convert coal to
oil for about ninety dollars a barrel so
again if the price of oil goes really
high it's possible that some of those
huge reserves of coal that we saw data
on earlier could be converted into oil
there's a both for tar sands and for
coal to oil there's an environmental
issue because the because you have to
you spent a lot of energy to get oil out
of tar sands a lot of energy you have to
dig then you have to bring the bring the
the oil up you have to crush it you have
to heat it to liquefy it so you're
spending a lot of energy so that the
lifetime carbon footprint of oil from
tar sands is much higher than the carbon
footprint of conventional oil and the
European Union actually environment
Directorate
last week issued a ruling which you may
have seen on this saying that tar sands
oil from tar sands imported into Europe
would have to pay a surcharge because of
its higher carbon content and I think
they reckoned the carbon content was
about sixty percent higher than
conventional oil and that the same in
the same ruling they said that the
carbon content of oil from coal is one
hundred percent higher than conventional
oil and so that would be an oil from
coal coming into Europe would also have
to pay a surcharge for that reason and
California also has as you will have
heard from Mike yesterday mike girard
california has its own environmental
policies in california has a surcharge
on athabasca oil coming from the
Athabasca tar sands because of its
higher carbon footprint in its hires
it's one more damaging environmental
friendly okay um right so this is just
us oil production I skipped this earlier
you can see that the of the north of the
oil fields in Alaska the North Slope of
Alaska are gradually running down those
production there's well past its peak
and it's not expected to turn up again
there's an increasing amount of activity
offshore in the US and that's expected
to continue but not to generate a huge
amount of oil that actually been quite
an interview some of you an increase in
oil production on shore in the US that's
partly because we've been to extract oil
from shale and there's no way I talked
about gas from shale earlier on and huge
amounts of gas being removed from shale
rock so there's also oil in shale the
same techniques as being applied to gas
can be applied to oil as well you can
hydraulically fracture shale rocks to
extract oil that's inside of those and
so we're expecting to see some increase
in onshore US production from partly
from some new genuinely new conventional
oil fields but largely from producing
oil from unconventional sources like
much sale
so us production expected to be
somewhere in the region of six million
dollars a day maybe somewhat above that
okay it's renewables very quickly this
is the growth of wind production in the
u.s. so the dimension the wind is the
most widely used renewable source in the
u.s. lizza he says it's interesting we
see the drop from here to here the drop
from here either annually sparse annual
installations of wind capacity this is a
period when the production tax credit
which I mentioned earlier was was
introduced on was available in this year
it wasn't available in this year was
available in this area it wasn't
available this year was available this
year it wasn't available this year you
can see how sensitive you know the
investment in wind is to the tax
incentives and how badly that policy has
been managed tax incentives available
one year not the next available one
you're not the next played havoc with
any long run so investment plans in this
area but for the last few years these
tax incentives have been available on a
longer-term basis and there's been a lot
of expected a lot of investment in wind
as making shows at the makeup of
incremental capacity additions to
capacity this is wind this is other
renewables this is gas this is igcc this
is conventional gas so you can see that
basically this is roughly what this is
roughly ninety percent of all additions
to capacity in the US either renewable
or wind the US is basically becoming a
renewables and wind economy and
renewables and gas economies or a real
orgasm for renewables basically read
wind so that very few other power
stations are being built at this point
some soul up this is world cumulative
installed wind capacity and the US is
this bar here this is Europe so the US
is slightly slightly less in total
installed capacity than Europe somewhat
more than China
and that was 2009 the last year I got
complete data for that wind is
economically attractive for onshore wind
in the u.s. the cost is about five to
six cents a kilowatt hour that's
competitive with gas and slightly
cheaper than coal and that's before you
allow for the various incentives that's
before you allow for Rex before you
allow for investment tax credits or
production tax credits so you know with
all of these things wind can be when can
make a profit it's not prices as low as
three cents a kilowatt hour or even less
than them so wind is competitive in the
US and you're seeing that's why you're
seeing this big build out of wind that
we saw a couple of sites back onshore
wind there's no offshore wind in the
u.s. what do you there New Jersey
there's when there are plans for power
stations often what you just isn't but
this one power station being built off
Cape Cod in Massachusetts right off the
Kennedy family is home and they spent
many years blocking it but they finally
lost so that's going up that should be
operating next year but that will be the
first offshore and then there's a
there's a backbone being built an
offshore power cable being built from
Boston down to south of Washington about
50 miles offshore and the idea about the
ideas that that that we are series of
offshore wind power stations will feed
power into that backbone and then from
there into the northern industrial areas
in the Northeast so there are plans for
wind to assure when to expend quite a
lot but this point offshore wind is
expensive related to onshore wind in a
mini capital costs of onshore wind or
about two thousand dollars a kilowatt at
capacity for the offshore it's more like
a five thousand dollars and then the
offshore wind you get a you know higher
capacity factor and you get a higher
wind speed and the output goes up with
the cube of wind speed power goes up
with the cube of the wind speeds have
you can double the wind speed it's
obviously very advantageous but at this
point that the u.s. offshore wind is
really a totally Northern European
there's nothing here Western ability
years like six cents yep that's pretty
no that's just raw Yeah right if you
have the forecast so if you if you take
the the capital costs and you amortize
them over a 30-year life and you assume
i think in working that are you some
suma thirty-three percent capacity
factor let's tell right
no I'm interested so what what capex you
would you be pallet wood you'll be
paying for a kilowatt of capacity in
Europe my million dollars from megawatt
so yeah here they reckon it's about a
thousand dollars a kilowatt I kill a lot
yeah yes right right right that's
speculatively 15 years okay well that
would account those two things where I
can't feel a difference yeah okay yeah
so what most of the wing producers in
the u.s. do is they sign a long-term
contracts with utilities which lock in a
price for the life of the power station
yeah the Catholics I mean the camp
causes all Catholics by Sigma D yeah
yeah yeah I don't know what's the oldest
wind turbine in Europe what's the oldest
wind turbine in Europe yeah right yeah
so the Yemeni calculations that most of
these numbers I take from this place for
Emeril National Renewable Energy Lab and
they're assuming short 20 to 30 years as
a life span on wind turbines I guess
it's an open question whether that's a
an optimistic assumption or not and then
yeah okay so anyway this is certainly
even if you for example or to cut the
life man down once you've added in these
are these allowances here which i showed
you before a very big wind is highly
competitive and even with the only a
fraction of those allowances when does
competitive
okay let's just talk finally just really
briefly about solar power the main story
here is again this is the same in the US
as in Europe is that the cost of solar
power has come down dramatically cost
per watt of capacities come down
dramatically in the last decade
basically and same sort of data here
it's you know you basically only three
or four years ago you were paying in
this country roughly eight to nine
dollars for water to capacity you can
now buy solar panels for roughly a
dollar twenty a dollar thirty for a
water capacity there's been a huge drop
in the price and that drop in the price
of solar panels hasn't really been
reflected in the cost of power coming
out of solar installations yet because
all of the solar installations currently
operating in the u.s. bought their
panels at much higher prices than
today's prices so we haven't really seen
any installations that have been turned
on that are paying you know this sort of
price for their for their panels but the
expectation that this is just one of the
attractive things about solar is that
although it's intermittent there is
something of a match between the time
profile of solar power production and
the time profile either the load curve
in a typical us and the theme in the
u.s. heating is all basically oil or
coal but cooling air conditioning which
is actually much more of a source of
energy demand than heating cooling is
entirely electric and in the summer the
u.s. electricity market is dominated by
demand for calling electricity for air
conditioning and here in the New York
for example is a huge peak in demand in
the summer because of a demand for air
conditioning and that's a very time of
day sensitive and one of the interesting
things about solar power is the disease
it matches that date on which notes it's
time curve matches that daytime peak
reasonably well during the summer when
there's a demand for air conditioning so
there is a lot of intermittent so you do
have more predictability than you do
with wind and
some match there so that's the current
module prices which as I said some
dollar twenty dollar thirty a kilowatt
the solar power is more expensive than
coal more expensive than gas somewhere
in the region eight to nine to ten cents
a kilowatt hour it could be competitive
if with coal for example at all had to
pay for its carbon dioxide or had to
capture and store its carbon dioxide but
it's not competitive at the moment
however what is interesting is that
although this is not competitive with
the wholesale market its competitive in
the retail market so in the u.s. you've
got a wholesale power market where power
cells are at five six seven cents a
kilowatt hour and you've got retail
markets well anyway you and I by our
power and those are anywhere from twelve
to twenty cents a kilowatt hour and this
is less than the retail price so what
you're seeing is a lot of what's called
off-grid solar in the US so a lot of lot
of operations are putting up solar power
which is at their own expense and
they're using this to bypass power from
the grid they're not feeding it into the
grid and most of the grid in the US
don't take power but they are using it
to bypass road power at least during the
daytime so there's a lot of these
example wal-mart stores in the USD
several these big box stores they have
huge amounts of roof space I have huge
parking space around them and what
they're doing is they're putting solar
panels on the roofs of their buildings
and solar panels over there parking lots
and they can get enough power from those
to power the stores during the daytime
and they can get that power for here ten
cents a kilowatt hour they're paying the
grid fifteen cents a kilowatt hour so
they're saving money by going off the
grid during the daytime then they go
back onto the grid at night when here
the solar power drops away and there so
that off period use of solar it's
actually growing quite rapidly
particularly in the south and west of
the US where you've got a lot of a lot
of Sun and very predictable some you're
seeing of increasing numbers of big no
shopping malls were the big stores with
lots of flat roofs a lot of ground more
a big big big footprint
using solar panels on the roof and
there's actually a company called Sun
edison which basically what when
companies like Walmart do this they
don't install the panel's themselves
they hire a company called SunEdison to
install the panels for them Sun at ease
and takes the panel's installs the
panels it collects the renewable energy
credits which I talking about before and
it sells the power to walmart on a
long-term power purchase agreement so
Walmart doesn't have its own capital
tied up in this sunedison provides the
capital and there's a dead now a three
or four sunedison was the first company
in this field but there's now three or
four companies copying that business
model and providing off-grid solar and
quite a big scope what depends on the
state you know in New Jersey the price
would almost be zero that's why many I
mentioned earlier that many New York
operate New York companies have shifted
their data processing centers for
example New Jersey in the pudding in
solar power that but for the roughly if
you go to California the effect on the
wrecks would be maybe one or two cents a
kilowatt out the direct prices are much
lower so it's not that's not a huge deal
there you get the investment tax credits
and the production tax credits to
possibly okay so I still run out of time
so let me wrap up really quickly you
know coal gas and oil the US has a lot
of coal a lot of gas those are the
mainstays of power production currently
with gas basically replacing coal and
they produce power somewhere in the
region of five to six seven cents a
kilowatt hour for the wholesale market
oil isn't used to all though us has a
lot of oil it's not used in producing
power because it's just too expensive
when is more or less competitive with
these solar is not but is we're close to
being competitive with these and so if
there was any any common in a region
where there's a price on carbon dioxide
emissions solar could be competitive
with with Gasol with cold so that
creature in California fix
and a couple of years time I haven't
mentioned geothermal it's a very site
specific energy source but the west
coast of the u.s. is seismically active
and there's a growing interest in
geothermal power there and trying to use
more cheerful mikonam geothermal power
is attractive obviously its base load so
it's your twenty-four-seven and the
prices thing to be low and the existing
base of existing geothermal power plants
in California producing a three to six
cents a kilowatt hour so that's very
attractive and then nuclear there's been
no nuclear reactors built as I'm sure
you're aware in the US since the 1970s
so the issue of what the cost of new
nuclear power would be is really rather
open another unclear you may have more
idea about that than I don't coming from
EDF the you know there's a wide range of
estimates of the capital costs of
nuclear power stations at this point
depending I guess I'm exactly what
technology is used and also they at
nuclear power stations are perceived by
investors as risky so that it's quite
hard to raise capital to fund nuclear
power stations risky partly because of
the overruns and the production costs
and the and in the building costs in the
building timetables and risky also
getting an operational sense so I think
it's unlikely they'll be any nuclear
power stations built in the US in the
near future and I'm not approving of
that I think it's unfortunate in many
ways but that's just a fact so I haven't
got a featured in the nuclear in the
discussion at all okay let me stop at
that point matter
yeah there's some hydro is attractive to
obviously the desert area here actually
imports a lot of hydro from Canada so we
get a lot of power here from hydro
quebec and it's lawrence seaway and on
the west coast there's a lot of
hydropower in the columbia river and in
the tennessee valley authority there's
not much extinction of hydro so going
forward I mean hydro capacity is pretty
much maxed out in the US if anything
there's pressure to to reduce hydro
because of the environmental impacts of
of dams on fish populations and river on
ecosystems in my godson in the there was
actually a court case in which the
Columbia River Authority was ordered to
remove some dams because of the effect
they have on salmon populations which
are now an endangered species in the US
the USS a thing called the Endangered
Species Act which makes it essentially
illegal to do anything which will affect
the survival chances of a species which
is listed as endangered and gives the
government considerable power to to to
make people make changes to enhance the
life chances of an endangered species
and so some of the Columbia River dams
may have to be removed because of their
impact on salmon populations and salmon
migration so it's so maybe you know
maybe in river hydro maybe so
run-of-the-river hydro you may see moral
but big big hydro dams I don't think
you're going to see any more off in the
u.s. I know
yes right yes yes that's right this
nobody ever said that policymakers are
rational
the amount of what yeah right no the
Environmental Protection Agency right
now is undertaking a study of the impact
of hydraulic fracturing on water and and
the possibility for recycling the water
there but at this point we don't really
have a North aura tative study of how
much water can be recycled how much it
can be cleaned I mean basically you take
water you put sand into it you put a
bunch of chemicals into it pump it down
into the into the shale at very high
pressure to fracture the stuff and then
some of that water escapes but some of
it can be recycled and reused and the
balance between recycling and escaping
is not clear obviously some has is too
much as escapes historically I don't
think they'll ever recycle one hundred
percent but I don't know what the upper
limit on the recycling can be in the EPA
is supposed to be writing a report on
this right now to be released later this
year or early next year and that will be
the first review authoritative statement
of of you know the water impact of
fracking in the u.s. yeah
thank you